the March for Life takes on a new purpose
on Friday the annual Gathering of thousands
of anti-abortion Rights activists
was held for the first time since
the Supreme Court overturned Roe versus
Wade with abortion no longer protected
by the Constitution Chief election
and campaign correspondent Robert
Costa looks at what that means for the March
the movement and the politics going forward
how far should that fight go it's a battle that
will continue I think when I say a battle it's
not a physical battle but I mean it's a spiritual
battle for the soul of this nation Evangelical
leader Franklin Graham son of the famed Billy
Graham was one of thousands of anti-abortion
activists who turned up in Washington Friday for
the March for Life arguing that the end of row is
not the end of their fight after the midterms last
year where does the abortion issue go from here
well I think the pro-life movement has always
been strongest at the Grassroots level so
Rose overturned but we still have a lot of work
to do but the persistence from conservatives on
abortion comes as the Republican party is at a
Crossroads some like former president Donald Trump
have blamed last year's disappointing election
results on the abortion issue being poorly handled
by Republicans who insisted on no exceptions
on abortion and I've made it very clear it may
take us as long to restore the sanctity of life
to the center of American law as it took us to
overturn Roe v Wade but I believe that far beyond
the politics of that question for the sake of the
nation we need to restore uh the sanctity of life
but in the early days of the 2024 presidential
race some possible Trump Rivals are shaking their
heads at Trump's assessment moving to the right
and challenging the competition to take further
action and would you nudge Governor DeSantis
to take further action I would nudge every
Governor to do what they can to back up their
pro-life record I think that that talking about
um situations and making statements is incredibly
important but also taking action and governing and
bringing policies to protect life are even more
important because that's what truly will save
lives Governor Christie gnome of South Dakota
where abortion is banned has been challenging
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis and other Rising
Republicans to do more to limit abortions in their
states sparking an informal policy standoff among
those who might run for president DeSantis signed
a 15-week abortion ban into law last year and
another possible candidate governor Glenn Younkin
is now pushing a 15-week ban in Virginia but many
attending the March acknowledged the politics
of an issue that has long been highly charged
remains complicated do you believe Republicans
should push more or less on this issue you
know what we're doing is in the right direction
currently I think that they need to be willing
Democrats need to be willing to
have a dialogue with Republicans
too meanwhile Democrats continue to push
on this issue as well and on Sunday vice
president Kamala Harris will deliver
a major address on abortion rights
in Florida five decades after Roe v Wade for
CBS Saturday morning Robert Costa Washington